[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is apollo and this is going to be a
video about the brand new tesla mobile
app so i talked about in one of the
previous videos that we'd be expecting a
major overhaul to the app pretty soon
and we finally got it fun fact it was
actually going to be one of the
questions i answered in the q a video
but i scrapped it but that was yesterday
when i was recording that and we didn't
really have the app yet it was just kind
of leaked a little bit we had some
screenshots now a couple of hours later
the app is live and it's beautiful so
both ios and android got this refresh at
pretty much the exact same time which is
pretty rare as far as the apps go but uh
yeah we'll go ahead and open it first
thing to notice right away is the icon
is new it's no longer that skeomorphic
3d look it's a lot flatter now the
splash screen is a lot flatter and then
immediately we get a representation of
the car at the top like everything about
the car is accurate the lights whether
they're on or off the wheels i do have
the winter wheels on now but when i put
the summers back on when it gets warm
it'll be pretty accurate and the paint
color and you can see the door is open
so let's go ahead and close the door of
the car
and it closes in the app too and then
everything else in the app all the
controls you have are exactly the same
in fact there's pretty much no
functionality added it still does all
the same stuff to the car with the car
it's basically just a fresh coat of
paint so at the top you have the car's
name and its status how many miles are
left on the battery and then you have
three little quick controls here one to
turn on the fan for the climate control
and the car will immediately start
heating up or cooling down two for a
keyless start if you don't have the fob
with you and three to unlock the car
and that will go ahead and unlock the
handles and you can see it pops out
right there and then below that are a
bunch of the more detailed controls that
used to be separated out into the tabs
at the bottom so for the climate control
if you turn that on oh hey sam you'll
immediately be able to change the
temperature inside the car to whatever
temperature you want obviously it's 66
now so going up to 73 requires heat and
you can see the little animation
turn red now again there's no new
functionality so it's not like you get
like the seat heating now you don't get
a steering wheel heating now or at the
defrosting none of that is added and i
feel like maybe there's some new plugs
in the api in this new app that will let
that be added in the future but as of
right now it's still all the same
functions as the last one just a little
faster so the controls here you get all
the same things that you had in the last
app so you can vent the roof again lock
or unlock the car flash the headlights
if you want honk the horn
it's really loud and then you can start
up the car right there and you can put
it in valet mode from the app charging
is pretty simple it just tells you what
your charging status is if you're
charging it'll update you on how fast
you're going and you can open the charge
port if you want and set charging limit
and of course the summon feature still
does all the same things it did before
connects to your vehicle and lets you
have it pull up out of a driveway out of
a tight space into a tight space
whatever you want it to do the car will
start moving
when it detects it has the room so
obviously there's no one in the car
but as you can see it's doing its thing
i'm just gonna have to trust that it
yeah it sees me cool
wait
hold up wait a second
good job so that's really pretty much it
it's a fresh coat of paint you get all
the information about the car it's all
accurate it's much cleaner now but again
there's no new functionality it does all
the exact same things that you saw in
the first video so if you're curious
about what it does and what it looks
like in action that video is still
accurate the one thing that did add
which is new on both android and ios is
fingerprint recognition so you now have
touch id on that's reflective touch id
on iphones and just fingerprint
recognition on my android phone
everything else is the same the referral
code is the same your vehicle
information is the same it's just uh
much better looking oh and for those
wondering the car itself has been
awesome in these last couple weeks you
remember the last video i did about the
tesla was because it was having issues
this is to update you on the fact that
it's been perfect since then so great on
that too anyway that's pretty much it
thanks for watching this quick video
hope you enjoyed and uh talk to you guys
in the next one
peace
[Music]